how do you spell your first name
yeah
let's go ahead and just focus on
breathing forward
shocking video shows what led up to the
arrest of Taylor Frankie Paul a Mormon
influencer known for referencing
swinging in her videos hi guys we are
going to be prepping for my kids because
for those of you that know I'm a
divorced parent so I do like a prep day
before my kids come for the weekend
I already have them
um because I got them a day earlier than
I thought so we are still gonna go get
groceries and prep for the weekend 28
year old Paul Rose to fame on Tick Tock
after saying her ex-husband Tate Paul
filed for divorce when she broke the
rules in their soft swinging
relationship did you um sleep with him
or just kiss him
I slept with him
nearly one year after her ex-husband
filed for divorce Paul was caught on
camera crying hysterically before her
arrest I'm always learning
okay so your last name is just Paul yeah
the video shows a clearly distraught
pulse speaking with police after a 9-1-1
call came in for a domestic violence
report on February 17th
9-1-1 what is the city and address of
hearing emergency there's like domestic
violence like somebody is screaming like
get off me there is like a woman a woman
screaming there's like the garage door
keeps opening and shutting it sounds
like she's trying to get out Harriman
Utah police arrive at Paul's home to
find her and her boyfriend 30 year old
Dakota Mortenson amidst an argument
after that police separate the pair and
begin to question Paul
what
what's up
I just want to be able to talk to you
without YouTube and figuring at each
other okay okay so go ahead like you can
say it or whichever okay so what's
what's your name Taylor I'm officer
rubebracht with the Harriman Police
Department okay the neighbors called in
saying they heard a bunch of yelling
thank you
okay so let's start let's start with
this how do you spell your first name
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
do you need paramedics no I'm good I'm
good
um have you had a little bit too much to
drink tonight I can smell the alcohol
pretty strong sure but not anything
crazy I went on a girl's land it came
home safe driving
okay I'm not I'm not worried about that
I'm just worried about like do I need to
call paramedics to come check you out no
no okay Paul
serves her
what did I do wrong because I can help
myself
what I did wrong
I'll meet the nose I Can Do Better well
it's it's not it's not Taylor look at me
it's not that you did anything wrong per
se
we are just the neighbors called in
thinking that someone's getting hurt no
one foreign
I'm just really hurting
I can get my husband to come get the
kids if that's easier I don't know what
he wants me
I don't want anyone the ones for me I'm
just so harder so tell me tell me what
happened to me he pushed me in the
garage and I don't give a like I just
want I just want to move on I don't give
a fuck about him I just wanna run
I hit him he pushed me I don't always
think about it
oh
I gotta get a drink please please can
you promise not to talk to him while we
go in there sure Paul says she went
quote ballistic during the argument
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you mean for me so I just I just
need you to tell me what happened
tonight so you you went out on a girl's
night you said that right yeah he didn't
pick me up from girls night and then
what happened and he was bitching me out
of the way home about so when you
describe that to me about what I guess
having fun with my girls
and
and he was going to a concert but he was
like we're not going to concert now he
came home
and and then we're fighting
and uh we're fighting on each other and
many like I was going at him I guess
hitting him and then he pushed me
into the kids stuff and then I went
ballistic because it was really so hard
and then I fought back and then we were
decided and I just want him out
and and
so I guess it's all
with the uh with you guys fighting
um do you have any injuries no I think I
I think I'm okay my fingers hurt I'm
okay can I see your hands yeah
I think I'm okay I'm good what about the
other side
oh
really
and then oh I'm sorry I just want my dad
investigators then speak with mortonson
all I've been trying to do for the last
hour and a half is to leave I mean I'm
just being bombarded stealing my quiches
jumping on my truck
slamming my doors like I I've seen
myself yeah I think my truck doors broke
like
she's on top of my truck jumping like
dude
I'm just I I can't even believe what
just happened you know uh let's go look
at your truck just like lost its words
Mortensen explains Paul is going through
a divorce which may have led to her
stress level he also explains to police
what led up to the argument
brightness so she's going through a lot
right now
um yeah with some divorce and stuff like
I think that's just been really hard on
her and she hasn't done anything and
that's a that's a different relationship
yeah okay yeah and so and that wasn't
that long ago so it's very fresh so she
so we got in a relationship like really
pretty soon after her divorce and so
that's why it's been hard it's just been
like a lot I think for her okay
um and yeah I mean I I mean yeah I think
she's just she's going through a lot and
she's the type to where
uh yeah it's hard for her acting to get
help you know like
um she fights it
so you guys come home
she starts getting angry yeah because
you're saying that you're wanting to go
home
yeah well I was trying to just take her
inside I was trying to help her in I was
like like let's go like you need to go
inside and she I think she was saying
something that she wanted to go party
still I'm like no like you can't
um yeah and then I went inside because I
was finally just like she was not coming
out so I was like okay well I'm and she
said her parents weren't here so I was
like oh perfect I was like I'm gonna go
are they actually in there no they
weren't it was uh like I don't know like
her niece or something like that I don't
know and so I went in there and was like
didn't get them I'm like hey Taylor's
like drunk he like couldn't get her or
something are they coming over no they
were they already left they were house
sitting for her watching her kids and
then she kept flying in and that's what
she was like freaking out on me in front
of them and I'm like whoa what what was
she saying oh crazy stuff I don't know I
think she was like I don't even know
what she was saying
um
I don't know something about her phone
she was going off about her phone and
then she chucked her phone at me
and then oh no she threw it on the
ground
and then uh
fast when officers approached Paul again
she tells them she was so scared during
the incident she lost control of her
bladder so I talked to
um I talked to Dakota tell me
tell me what happened with the
um the little wooden thing in the garage
in his truck like what happened outside
at the truck
um oh all I know is that I was so scared
that I peed my pants
he pushed me into it I I reacted sure I
threw it on via phone Mortensen later
tells officers that's untrue
she's saying that she was so scared
that she peed off like gosh no and
that's not true and she made that like
she made that point multiple times when
it so when I when I first arrived at the
at the house
I I don't remember ever seeing her pee
herself and like
and
like I feel like that's something that I
would have easily recognized absolutely
I get that's a lie I mean she's she's
just lying that's not true eventually
the responding officer tells Paul she's
under arrest well the the hard part is
that like I'm getting two different
different stories okay as far as
tonight's concerned based on
um
what I've seen and and what's taken
place
um at this time you're going to be
placed under arrest
for a DB for domestic violence okay so
before I talk to you more about it and
you turn around place your hands on your
back
so is he not
I might know
so he pushed me and I'm under arrest why
I can talk to you more about it that's
fine but I'm just curious why
if
I wanted to talk or not yeah and just
give me a second
why am I embarrassed
so you're going against her his word
against mine correct
um it's based on the evidence that I'm
seeing at the like here tonight what's
your evidence just curious just all the
stuff on the ground and you throwing
things at him
and
ask him
because
when he sees this he's not going to
agree to it
officials can then be seen discussing
the arrest with Mortensen the reality
that's the reality of this is that you
were victimized tonight and that's why
we're here is we don't want
we don't want uh further violence yeah
and maybe this is the reality check she
needs that like hey I need to get help
things in chat
so
um I just want to talk to you
go there real quick sorry but one kid
just puked
um I mean I'm glad the parents showed up
I don't know which one's which the
little girl the one upstairs okay
um what is
do you know the daughter's name
do you have a birthday
it's
that's okay
do they have the same last name yeah or
is it a different one well she's not
divorced yet well she is she just hasn't
changed
yeah okay
um yeah like I can't I can't make you
fill that out yeah it's voluntary
um but I mean that's that's your side of
the story again she's alleging a
different side yeah I mean I guess
that's the only thing like if she's one
to like push stuff then like I'm gonna
have to but like I I truly just want her
to like just get help and just that's
that that's I understand that and that's
what I'm hoping this results in I'm not
I'm not trying to jam anyone up or take
him to jail to take it yeah like I want
nobody the problem solved does someone
get charged then or something she is
going to be charged with domestic
violence oh my gosh and but that's I
know that that's hard to hear but that's
the reality of the situation and I'm
glad that it wasn't worse because like
what if she cried like she was throwing
stuff at you oh and damaging your
property or something like what if yeah
what if the off chance that she grabbed
a kitchen knife like it's our already
clear that she wasn't thinking straight
right yeah normally normally in your
relationship it's lovey-dovey hunky-dory
right but in this specific case that
can't be ignored
what if she wants to grab the knife or
something else and it escalates again so
the main thing is a reality check saying
like hey that's not okay and ignoring
it's not going to help the problem
either like you guys waking up tomorrow
morning and acting like it never
happened or having one little
conversation and maybe like a smack on
the wrist that doesn't typically help
dude before her arrest Paul confirmed to
officers she was not receiving mental
health treatment
do you have a therapist or anybody you
go to
no
you ever talked with somebody about
how you're feeling divorce no any
abusive people no I have not
I'm not yet I should he's probably a
pretty good idea they can be pretty
useful you know you might not feel like
this normally this might be kind of due
to
a little bit of alcohol always raises
all of our emotional state it kind of
makes the emotion take over the rational
I don't know if you noticed that with
you but no a divorce or alcohol or not I
feel awful so yeah you're good you're
good it's probably a little bit easier
to keep under control though when you're
when you have something yeah
yeah but a therapist can help you work
through a lot of those things if you're
feeling like this a lot
it's probably in your best interest to
talk to somebody about it following her
arrest Paul took to tick tock explaining
she has since started therapy uh I also
got on Zoloft to help with my depression
and anxiety I'm on week four so I don't
know if I've seen a major difference yet
but I'll keep you guys updated on that I
also started EMDR therapy and so far
have loved it we're just working on all
the trauma and kind of gonna start
diving into how we can help cope with it
Paul now faces multiple charges
including aggravated assault and
domestic violence in the presence of a
child causing injury she has since
entered a not guilty plea in all of the
charges reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie